I want to jump to this story let's get
cultural we have this one from
thegamer.com they say star field isn't
woke you're just afraid of the future
now uh many of you may not be familiar
with Starfield it's a video game and a
controversy has emerged because you can
choose your pronouns in the game
another game just came out called
Baldur's Gate which is also sparking
some uh some culture War outrage that I
think is worth talking about because
there was a funny meme and it said uh
gamers are entering the culture War you
know what is it what's going to happen
now it's like gamergate was the
beginning of the culture War when when
people playing video Gamers got upset
over a variety of issues including uh
gaming companies paying media Outlets to
write favorable reviews for them but
this is what happened
here's the story star field has products
actually uh Ian can you explain what
star field is Starfield is a game by
Bethesda it's their newest launch so
like Elder Scrolls and Fallout this is
the new one and it's a space game where
you can fly around from planet to planet
and experience different biomes I think
it's first person first new uh IP by
Bethesda in 25 years you've actually
been playing it Kellen you said yeah
yeah uh I've not really encountered any
wokeness I mean the pronouns thing was
already default to he him so I didn't
even touch it when I started the game
but I'm curious what this article talks
about because so far I've enjoyed it I
haven't run into any nuts is it like
Fallout like exactly so what Fallout 76
should have been except in space like it
just works well you know it's very
in-depth I like it so far they say
shortly after Early Access began this
weekend a clip went viral featuring a
bald British man screaming about how
Starfield is desperate to remind us of
the current day with its use of pronouns
and body diversity they say hundreds of
years in the future a universe that
reflects the progress made within our
own allows players select the pronouns
people in their lives choose to address
them this choice is respected and is an
obvious component of making your
character in The RPG's opening moments
so uh I I I got a question
pronouns are only used not in your
presence
or if someone's speaking about you with
not with you not privy to the
conversation how does it work in a video
game when it's a first person game and
you're involved in every conversation
they'll probably talk about you in front
of you to prove they're doing it C
doesn't want to go over there anymore
can you type in your pronoun or do you
want a list you can select from uh I
think it's a list dude I gotta say I
watched I watched the intro I watched MF
Pally time play I think it was Pally
time play the intro and it was it was
rough man it was like woke it was like
girl boss this old woman our field was
yeah is like the boss and she has no
Charisma and you're like why is this
woman the main character right now and
then this dude this beta dude comes up
and he's like I'm gonna give you my ship
for no reason and that's the that's the
beginning of the game and then it just
dumps you and it's like wow this is like
well that's the beauty of the game if
you can completely take a left turn if
you don't want to follow that that's how
you know that's all that's Oblivion
right so you can you don't have to
follow that storyline if it's rubbing
you the wrong way I like that having the
option you know Starfield doesn't even
push the progressive boat all that much
from what I can tell most of its
companions abide by the tech actuality
of the player when it comes to romance
while going with the non-binary gender
option will also lock you to a specific
protagonist voice that can't be changed
no matter how you might sound or look in
reality which brings me to the next
story which is um Baldur's Gate which I
also I just started playing Baldur's
Gate
um and this was silly and I almost just
couldn't do it sorry whatever I'm 37.
the wokeness in this game was beyond was
was almost just I just I just okay look
usually when I play these games I just
do like random character I don't care
and the name will be like random letters
whatever dude it's a first person game
you know you're sneaking around with uh
Baldur's Gate it's a more of like an
overhead uh turn-based RPG
but with Mother's gate you can be when
you're creating you create two
characters to start with and you create
one more directly and then one as a
companion and so I'm like okay you know
balder is gay like Ian tried playing it
I'll play this one and so in the
character creation you can choose body
type one two three or four I think
there's four body types there's
basically thin woman man fat woman and
fat man or like wide body I guess then
there's gender identity and voice so you
can have like a type 1 body which is
female with a dude's face and like a
female voice like you know I don't know
or or you can have like a woman with
like a dude Voice who identifies as a
man identity is actually a character
characteristic in the game so you can
take a female totally female character
in every possible way and then say
identifies as a man and I've I just I
I'm like what is the purpose of this so
here's what ends up happening I always
just do like random character creation
like yeah I don't care now Baldur's Gate
is like dnd's with a lot more
complicated choices you have to make
but let me just tell you something funny
happens in the woke future of video
gaming let me explain
when you play Fallout 3 and you you are
you can choose your character male or
female if you choose male and then click
randomize it will choose a random
haircut with random facial features and
make a random looking guy if you choose
female you can do the same thing random
looking women with random looking hair
like the hair could be long could be
short could be spiky whatever you could
have scars you have tattoos but when you
mix it all together
and I pressed randomized the first thing
I got was a purple haired
man big masculine man face with a female
purple haircut bright pinkish purple
with big boobs who talk like a dude and
then I was just like if the character
can be male and female at the same time
random typically gives you something
that is
particularly
how what's the what's the right word
egregious no no like atypical not normal
like if you chose guy and then a
randomized guy in another video game
you'll get some like random guy and I'll
be like Oh I'm a guy I'm Owen but with
Baldur's Gate it's like every character
with some weird amalgam of male and
female yeah I couldn't get my guy to
stop looking like a woman it was really
frustrating and there's like I press
randomize one and it's like a a dude's
buzz cut with a female face and a super
ripped man body but talking like this
like a woman I'm like identifying as a
woman but looking like a big ripped guy
or like the fat woman body with a big
bearded dude's face talking like this
I'm like it's just
you know look it's one thing to make a
character based on you but the issue is
when they mix it all together and then
when I was creating the next character
who apparently is like a main character
or something similar it's it's it's
similar it's just like random features
that don't mix and it's by I don't know
it's just crazy it's just pure chaos the
game's fine I actually enjoy the
mechanics I wanted to spend no time on
character creation so I kept hitting
random and it kept giving me these like
these bla I don't Blasphemous is the
right word but these like things that
were like abhorrent to react to Nature
they were like and I just kept hitting
random until a normal person appeared
and I took the first one I saw it that's
right good enough I was just I'm like I
don't understand what I'm supposed to do
with this maybe it's just like uh it's
supposed to emulate what game devs look
like they're like they're building it
off themselves
people have pointed that out that
characters and movies tend to look like
the writers of these movies or the
graphic designers like seriously there's
like a meme about it where it's like
there's a woman and she's and she's got
like frizzy hair and glasses and she's
like I made a game and the character is
literally her and it's like okay but
this one I I agree with you Abomination
might be the word yeah hideous the
physical characteristics that you get
don't affect the character's ability
right so if you're sometimes if it looks
really ripped it's not more strong and
if it's not no it's about the same in
some games it matters because of hit
boxes like how big your character is
determines if someone is like attacking
you but not not this game this game is
like a turn-based RPG with a bunch of
different stats I the game's actually
really fun
um it's kind of like I don't know I'm
I'm only like an hour in and it's a bit
nonsensical like random things are just
happening but but I'm having fun with it
and it's a cool mechanics and I like the
RPG Styles D and it's basically DND but
it I almost turned it off right away
when I'm playing this game and it's just
like there I don't I don't understand
the purpose of identity in the game like
seriously the character doesn't seem to
be influenced or anything by this but
there was a funny meme
which uh actually got me you know I
started I I found after I started seeing
all the stuff where a guy is complaining
that he bought the game but all of the
dude characters keep trying to bang his
dude he's like my character's just like
an arranger guy and all of the the
companions keep trying to have sex with
me like what is going on why are they
all gay and that that was really
interesting to me in this in this
concept of where woke gaming goes in
most games there was the protagonist his
allies and then maybe his love interest
maybe but now because these games are
becoming more open world and they want
to entertain all identities every
interaction has to have a component of
some sexual or romantic Endeavor whereas
games did not used to have that they
would have like one love interest that
you could maybe now it's just like
you've made a guy character well all the
guys are gay and they want to do you and
do you want that in your video games
like is that do you want it dude
exactly I feel like if you wanted to it
to be like who are you in love with
you'd play like Sims 2 or whatever you
wouldn't play this game that seems
strange to me that's been my biggest
issue with this I could really care less
it's just like tell me a good story I
want to play a good video game to learn
a good story not spend 15 minutes in
character creation like I just feel like
they're hiring these teams to focus on
love interests and purple hair when it's
like yo like Tim said I want to just
fight the dragon man every come on like
seriously give it a try if you have the
game anybody who has the game probably
experiences already but if you haven't
I'm not suggesting you buy just for this
I'm having fun with the game so far it's
like it's pretty fun so it's it's a tad
complicated in a lot of ways but it's
worth it but just go to the character
creation hit random and you're gonna go
if it's anything like Divinity 2 there's
a lot of combinations so like one guy
can squirt oil on the ground and the
other guy can shoot fire at it and make
it explode so yes I believe you can do
that that's what the game's all about
for me not who is the character gonna
have sex with and it's it's rough for
kids like if you want to like your 12
year old play a game and there's nudity
in that game you can turn on and off and
the first thing it asked me when during
the game I was like do you want nudity
yes or no yes and yes is the default I
said yes
do not give your kids this game it's
like real life Solomon Gamora mm-hmm
yeah look the game's fine uh like the
gameplay is pretty great I'm enjoying it
it's a lot of fun uh you like roll a D20
and see it I I have some critical
successes that are really fun yeah but
uh I would not give uh uh anyone like
any any child in my family my future
child or like my you know my nephews or
nieces or whatever I wouldn't give this
a game because they're gonna be confused
by why the character like at the
character creation stuff pronouns
identity and all that stuff that's
creepo indoctrination and so that story
about starfield's interesting they're
like it's not even that woke it's just
in the future they respect pronouns bro
pronouns are cult garbage nonsense not
even every language has pronouns that's
the crazy thing it is your weirdo
Americanized white liberal cult that's
not what the future is sorry have a nice
day yeah from what I've seen with
Starfield like I'm trying to play
devil's advocate here because it to me
it's only that was only a tiny component
component was the pronouns to me they
gave that project to a small team or one
or two employees and said have fun I I
think it's a two-edged sword for that
same reason I think the game's so great
I think they've had a lot of people just
be able to create their own stories and
like story lines that you can play
through in the game so you're gonna get
some weird stuff but you're also gonna
get some really unique gems in my
opinion do you think it's better than
Fallout 4 no no uh I don't think I don't
think it's better than Fallout
um are you a video game guy that's still
good I like it though no but um I you
know I think whoever made this game
you know Russia and China never would
allow anything like this within like a
thousand miles of their border and I
think in America we have a really big
problem with this sort of stuff
indoctrinating the youth confusing them
like Tim said at a young age about all
these these things that they shouldn't
be thinking about they should be when I
played video games when I was younger it
was like Wii Sports you know it was just
dumb stuff like that now you got all
this I mean there is a vested interest
that is pushing this trying to push
people down this path and that path
ultimately is about not having babies
and doing freakish stuff yeah like Mario
would save the princess you'd be like I
saved the girl there my my male like my
ancestral DNA is lit on fire because I
saved the princess but now it's like
Mario walking in with his shirt he's
kind of sweaty and like I don't want to
see him pushing the princess up against
the wall and like them making out like
you don't need to add that stuff to
Super Mario Brothers and a lot of these
new games are like
they're going so cinematic but like to a
fault I don't know I mean I guess how
many how many of these games or shows
really need that component in it I don't
think you need it at all but I'm from an
era where they didn't have it so well
and I think it's because some people are
just more they expect sexually explicit
content more casually all the time now
and I would blame that on pornography
and the readily available access that I
mean people are like it's not compelling
unless you see this but actually you
guys are Testaments fact that like video
games were compelling when they had
strong story lines they're for sure
moving us to a game that's a movie that
is a porn where you are the main
character in VR where you have an open
world with abilities and but you can
also have sex like that's where we're
headed it's it's we're heading to a
world which is going to be open world VR
anything you want at all you're going to
eat ice cream all day you're gonna eat
chocolate cake now like for the time
being the VR stuff that exists there's
no point in playing a game where you eat
cake because you don't actually
experience the dopamine hit from eating
the cake but once they get that neural
link going oh yeah then people are going
to be eating chocolate cake all day what
about drugs if they could if they could
induce like a dopamine reaction in your
brain by taking digital heroin in the
game you're like my character's gonna
shoot up or whatever the hell it is yeah
I think that'd be illegal
because it would cause the exact same
problems triggering dopamine release or
whatever would cause the same price
artificially or through chemical
induction I think it would just cause
you serious problems they'd have to ban
it but don't know how you do it you're
gonna go to like neural link drug dens
where they're like we can bypass the
patch and the security features to
trigger whatever feeling you want yeah
because at first it'll in the game
you'll be taking the drug and then
you'll be getting the feeling in real
life but then they'll be like no no in
the game you don't it's illegal to take
the drug in the game and they'll be okay
I'm just gonna stare at flowers in the
game but you're still gonna get the
feeling and then they'll be like we
can't stop because basically clicking
like like looking at all your likes on
social media is producing dope and being
kind of like a drug scrolling not
scrolling have you guys watched the
peripheral on Amazon yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah and she's got that
weird like it's almost like she's
hungover when she comes out of the uh I
forget if it's a computer game or
whatever it is they're on like a branch
timeline but when she disconnects she's
all disoriented and like weak and
everything so I wonder if we'll get
something like even if drugs aren't
related that people are just so used to
being in the VR when they come out it's
just a total shock to the system yeah
guys I I have a confession to make
last night I went to go live Moss
have you yeah you deserve it and when I
walked when I walked in they had big
touch pads and I did not talk to a human
where Taco Bell oh Lamas live mass and I
got I got a cheeseburger Adida crunch
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time